how would that capture the flag though
well i i it's i don't mind playing it
it's just it's not my preferred
mode like right it's like you know it's
like
no it's not even
i don't mind any of the game modes like
but when it comes to
like the actual modes i prefer that
classic arena 4v4
because
yeah i i'm just not a big fan of like
eight people fighting over vehicles and
it's just playing it it gets so messy on
there and then everywhere i turn around
getting shot at three or four different
directions like i said
that was jealous did have a bad fun in
the clips and put the clips up i don't
sound like that
i mean i was playing with friends too
like you would never catch me in that
mode by myself
that's why after like i left that i
never booted the halo infinite beta back
up because it's just like
i have no interest in that like i've
never been a big team battle guy
no no i didn't even i think i probably
played 10 war zone matches the entire
halo 5.
oh
how many you said ten
like like ten matches though the entire
time hey what five was that but what
about that was like okay
that was their version of um
of big team battle big team battle yeah
it was yeah it's a little bit different
it was different but yeah but for sure
that was what they had in terms in lieu
of regular big team battle yeah yeah no
i think before i pass this off i was
going to say like what about just like
how the game look how how how it ran
what your thoughts are now it ran fine i
mean i don't think the game like i
personally think halo 5 looks better
but you know i i don't i think it's more
like art wise
than like in terms of the most but
you know it ran fine like you know i saw
people complaining about like the
performance on pc
yeah so this is why i can't deal with
that pc stuff because it's like look
like at the end of the day
they're making that game for like
mad different graphics cards like yeah
like and then they got to deal with you
know maybe you have a different cpu like
i'm not dealing with none of that
drivers like you know what king guess
what happened king what i clicked the a
button on the series x and it worked and
we're fine right
yeah it's just like i get it the pc is
the is the best place to play
but it's like look like it's not the
most convenient by far and i'm not
trying to deal with all that nonsense i
just want to play my game question
that's all you said something about it
um
halo 5 looking better
that's my issue like
so all right you played halo 5's
multiplayer and you played a lot of it
right
and now seeing this
you said it looked better
what do you mean like graphically speed
wise uh feel i just think like
aesthetically it looks like okay
yeah and brad said they have to twerk
the uh tweak the the time to kill no
they don't
have the target they have to twerk the
time
i don't i don't think they have to mess
with that at all i think the time to
kill is perfect yeah like if you want
quicker time to kel go play call of duty
right
like there's a reason that the time to
kill is the way it is in halos because
you got a shield
right you know it's not one of those
things where you know in the time it
takes to kill you
in halo you could kill three people in
call of duty yeah
and there's a reason for that that's why
a lot of people don't get really upset
when it comes to being killed a lot of
the times because
a lot of the times if you're better than
the other person you have enough time as
long as you don't try to run there's a
lot of people that try to run in halo
instead of halo's design where if you
start taking damage you turn around and
fight you don't run right right
you don't be a sucker
that's how the halo
uh the halo jump happened
is because the headshot sponges
no
headshot sponges like no i didn't get no
issue like that man
like the br i was three three hits man
three click three three shots they
they're they're out
no doubt no doubt shot oh shout out to
bg in the building he said the mag was
better in previous halos
yeah it was but you know what that can
we agree you know maybe that mag was a
little broken in previously
slo-mo says don't give them excuses no
i'm look i'm definitely not giving them
excuses i'm just telling you where i
play i got that issue
listen slow-mo plays a division let's go
oh damn
jesus yeah you had to go like that so so
man did you get a chance to get nah
unfortunately i think i didn't get my
game on but okay i'll comment okay maybe
maybe later today is this the lawn right
but let me see real quick what i did see
right through the video i watched a lot
of videos um
the physics are there and for me when it
comes to halo physics
yeah you can do whatever you want you
know halo you could you throw a grenade
and like you if you throw a grenade
uphill it's gonna come back downhill and
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna do
something wild and it's gonna cause the
chain reaction of things to happen and
for me that's halo right it gives halo
there's a weight to halo that other
games first person shooters don't have
right yeah and and i saw all of that
i saw wild stuff i saw people doing
crazy stuff with the grappling hook
right oh the sandbox is crazy the
sandbox is what halo range
but this is
greater than i've ever seen yeah i'm on
a sand box level
so i agree with addict on the way it
looks because i from the beginning i was
like
it took a step backwards because they
wanted to do that classic thing which i
don't necessarily agree with i get it
but i don't necessarily agree with but
if they have that feel down because halo
5 felt good didn't necessarily feel like
classic halo right
it was still that thing about like the
physics weren't necessarily the same and
it's for me halo is physics it's always
it always has been and to me they they
have that down to a t right so i'm
excited to play it
i'm gonna be real with you guys man like
i think after playing this as long as
they don't make any drastic changes i
think they can relatively get get caught
uh get halo back to some relevancy of
what it used to be
clearly was because i feel like halo
wasn't amazing amazing back then like
god like when it comes to first-person
shooters just have very few like
competition fortnite apex you know call
of duty's starting to come back to a lot
of point but i do feel like it could be
one of those contenders like i i really
have fun you say that
one of those i kind of agree with you
because it's like it feels first of all
we haven't seen it in a while so we
missed it right and then the way the
stars are aligning
you know with obviously the situation
with activision and you know their whole
thing in the building you know the
accounts the accusations whatever and
from you know a lot of people you know
not super thrilled so far what i'm
hearing about vanguard so far
then we just heard shout out to grub we
had him on defining duke the early world
on the street about battlefield ain't
ain't sp
peachy so i was just like where and that
threw me and maddie off because we was
like where like we he again it's early
it's alpha things can change but the
initial impression is mcconnell so it is
to your point attic it is feeling like
it is being set up for halo to execute
and for the most part what we're seeing
is people are enjoy really enjoying
themselves playing multiplayer okay
the biggest thing i'm worried about is
just the content at launch that's the
biggest thing i'm worried about like
because it's just like
i know
how these type of service games react
and i and i'm not saying this right or
wrong
because i do feel like if you went to
people back in the day and asked them
you know would you prefer to play your
favorite game
for six months or prefer like a ct's
approach where you know maybe it's not a
huge with the content at the very
beginning but you'll be playing this
game guaranteed if you love this game in
a year two years from now would you
prefer that approach would you prefer
them to just go to the next straight to
the next project you know what i'm
saying right and and i think you know
it's slippery slope with that kind of
logic and that kind of you know uh area
but i i'm kind of leaning towards the
the
just for these multiplayer type of games
i'm leaning more towards the service
games because the games like destiny we
see that this works
like sure some a lot of games
as in the majority of them doesn't come
out with a whole lot of content at
launch
but i feel like
it's better overall for the for the
health of the game in the end because
look you see you see these for all we
know they could have put all that time
and seed thieves into a game that they
thought the community oh no no doubt but
because they they made it the way they
did they did the the the path the way
they did they made the game the
community wanted not the game they
thought the community wanted i'm not
saying
that type of service works for
everything because it doesn't right but
i am saying that you know there are a
lot of cases where it has worked out
extremely well for the actual game yeah
that they came out with that way well
cfd is an example i mean obviously when
when it first came out apex legends yeah
like it wasn't feature heavy and it was
a lot of room for improvement but as we
see now see if these is killing it like
as king used to say
the billions
the billions and the billions you know
just because you don't like something
doesn't mean right that the masses
which i'm guilty of because i wasn't a
fan per se of it and to see where it's
at and i think again we talked with matt
we pulled up the concurrent numbers just
on steve malone it was over the ten
thousand mark and that was just that
shout out to um ben the mayor he he
plays that religiously they have a
strong community on the other platforms
it it's it's going it's going well for
them so to your point yeah i mean i
don't personally like when all the
features are not there and launch i'm
still gonna i don't want them to get
into that habit but
for the long term of the game as long as
the foundation is solid and then they
continue to iterate and continue to
improve but see that's where you have to
see if the consumer likes the product
that you have
right so you give them
the basic what what your premise is like
that's what apex was apex is getting the
premise first and then built on top of
the premise right it's like i said it's
a slippery slope because at the end of
the day you could be making a game that
no one wants but you don't know it
because you're not giving a massive
amount of people i think that we they
need to
take advantage of preview programs more
than they do see these should have been
in the preview program
hold up i think you guys should be able
to hear me fine i don't know
um i don't even know what that is barely
visible clearly visible
barely visible
uh
all right so it seems like that's what
they want
english like text language subtitles
sure
sure
all right
everything sounds fun
i think we got a winner
hold up let me double check everything
for those of you that was there for the
beginning when you saw the
when you heard
the podcast in the background
was that something that
you liked is that something that i
should really
look into like putting
the audio of previous podcasts in the
background like that carries what you
guys have to say
so what's happened is solve has
exchanged his battletoads token
for this game
that was another
podcast that wasn't
i gotta turn on the audio
yeah i think um
i don't know exactly how i feel about it
yet
let me make sure that the music is in a
decent
couldn't really hear it yeah
testing testing testing okay that sounds
good
all right all right
all right that that's cool the
the rain
is coming through
the controller i don't know if you guys
can hear that but the rain's coming
through the controller
all right so
character
could you character design could use a
little work but it's not too bad
heavy attack
oh you punch through walls
perry's left
light is back
oh
what's going on
who are you
i don't know but i think i'm about to
fight all of it
yeah we don't play here
oh
got something to say
oh
man he don't care he he just hitting
chicks like it's nothing
oh
come on come on
took a whole room on full black belts
that seemed very plausible
a whole room full of black belts guys a
whole room full of black belts
i don't know about that i don't know
about that
this dude got a stab i thought you said
they'd put up a fight i'm barely
breaking a sweat
oh
don't be arrogant
but then again i just fought a whole
room full of black belts so
hold up let's let's look
looks like some students from a high
school
what's going on here
let's go upstairs
why they all holding they they
they need
did he hit them all the same exact way
except for this dude this dude's holding
his arm
but the arm's kind of going through
okay so it's glitching but it's going
through his
his arm
okay
nothing there
now how does the balance of the the
music sound
how is the balance of the music sound
is it pretty balanced
hold up
x
who the hell is that
oh there's two of them there's two of
them they got
beer bottles
come on
[Music]
oh look how many people is in here
oh i stepped foot anywhere i want
i'm not gonna wait for you to come to me
i'm coming to you
we we don't play that game
all right so that's how you
okay
come on
[Music]
let's go
oh
come on let's go
i like the music music's pretty good i
like the music
can you go through this door
no
okay
who's all in here
where is he
oh let's just not say anything
oh stop
we've got to lose
yang
of course
let's do about the whoop i add
seafood
yeah see but you shouldn't be doing that
you should be looking for assassins at
all times
you shouldn't be looking and playing
board games you should be looking for
assassins at all times it's not my fault
that they got soft on
uh
i should never have taught you
oh he's gonna kill us
by returning here tonight
you've given me a second chance
oh what's about to happen guys
i'm feeling we've got to lose
oh oh oh
come on
stop him stop him
oh he knocked me into the other room we
fighting in the other room now
look how bad that rain looks
it's just an indie game addict just just
an ending
when i look into your eyes
i see nothing but a fight what's up
nylon
oh you
slapped me get up
okay so there's like a little focus bar
come on
oh god
you guys got to give me a second man
oh got the focus far back
oh
i strike
did i make a blind
okay
thank you
no problem we took that dude out with no
problem
might have hit us once or twice but no
problem
a boy
all right so
that's who we are we're not that dude
the whole game
the whole game's about fighting these
people
i love how he won't do it he making
someone else do it
does he not die
oh they're glowing
father
[Music]
all right so
you're shuffling's kid i guess i guess
that's his name
all right let's see what we got here
deflect perry
so they'll
directional throw okay
come on
all right so
shadow round man
no you you don't kill your own dad uh
this is the little kid
uh the other dude killed your own dad it
looks like
to avoid
all right so this is like
[Music]
oh no hold up
hold l1
[Music]
just before getting hit
okay okay okay
so they're teaching you all the things
you might need to fight in this game
what is this
[Music]
look
[Music]
i hope i'm doing the palm strike right
hold up
oh she whooping my ass
come on let's
go the artist i'm assuming you're
fighting the people that's on his team
right now
all right all right all right
[Music]
i think they're giving you like
a low key
okay that's a sh
she got one arm
this one arm chick about to wipe my ass
down kick his whole circle okay
come on
come on let's go
that's if it ever comes out for xbox i
don't know
how much of a funding this game
was done on um
on xbox i mean on playstation
oh here's the leader
come on man
[Music]
i guess he this isn't his how's the game
so far so good
i can't say much too you know i just
started it man i just started it i don't
know too much you got to give me more
time
also he's looking for
trained and raised by my father and she
we were close he taught me a lot over
the years he disappeared with his wife
and daughter when i was still a child he
can he came back years later and
murdered my father in cold blood
trained and raised by my father in sufu
now he lives above the city and runs a
traditional healing sitter but he
doesn't appear to be in touch with the
world
not really i've never really uh trained
in martial arts
doesn't like background stuff but
not
formally trained at anything
raining strikes
okay
where do i go
he's one of the who cut my throat he's
the one who cut my throat that night
he's the first on my list he works for a
gang as president and never leaves the
warehouse
okay so we we we looking for revenge i
got you
this is gonna be a mini game
all right
that's enough of that let's get to the
actual
story maybe you actually got to
click on all of these
alongside my father trump was highly
known and respected among the city's
masters she was always the first to
defend the un underprivileged and
helpless and always had a strong sense
of just i don't know why she turned
against them but she will pay for that
she now has become the head of a vast
and extremely powerful corporation she's
still helping those in need opera with
the greatest means but her sudden
appearance and wealth is very suspicious
chris passes hard to investigate all i
know is that she is japanese and rumors
tied to her in the underworld the
underworld world
something must have happened to force
her to
her into exile here in china she now
runs an art museum she now
there day and night on her most
ambitious
exhibition to date
i guess that's the museum
seen i met him several times when i was
a kid our father knew
each other's as kung fu masters i can't
believe he took part in their deaths
he's involved in a event called the
burning
uh taking
place in the club i need to get there
early when it's not too crowded because
i don't know exactly how this game's
rolling right now
all right so let's see
all right maybe i go to this thing here
oh so this is like an uh a skill tree
okay
it's more stuff you can unlock
i did that
i did all that
the squats
is these like missions did i just agree
to do a mission
start
so these are missions i have to go
through and do
all right so let's see
they've blocked the entrance to the
warehouse
need to find another way inside
all right here we go
nothing here for you no
there's nothing here for you buddy
i ain't getting lost
oh you want some too
he can't keep up
you hit me one time and i can't keep up
not with that nonsense
all right so let's see
let's go upstairs
what's up
i'm not giving them time i'm not
they they they're getting dealt with
we don't give people time in the attic
world man
any regrets now
yeah
i let you hit me once that's my regret
i love how they're not seeing this
they're not hearing it
what's up man
i can make it
just need a run at it
all right let's go
oh look at this chick
oh
[Music]
oh so you get a little bit of your
health
may he be throwing glass and stuff at me
that ain't fair i'm so tough after all
hold up
i could pick up a glass too okay
this is getting thrown against someone
here in a minute
open it
open up
oh there's a lot of people in here check
this [ __ ]
okay
oh i like the
the change in scenery
i respect that
we got to get rid of this chick now
come on what you guys doing let's go
let's go guys
you guys could do better
nerves get the better of you
come on man let's go
you please yourself
i like the switching
and how they look things i really
enjoyed that i think that's a really
unique thing that you don't really see a
lot of developers do
i hope they do that more that was
actually really fun
is there anyone in here
i ain't playing
they know i'm here for disaster
oh you got a vault
oh bam
camera angle a little wonky i won't
admit that the camera ain't go a little
wonky
i'm not really feeling the camera angle
as much guys what's up i'm here for
dinner
this is all miscommunication
i was invited here
this is all a miscommunication
stop it please let me explain myself
i pity you
let me handle this dude
sit chill there for a second i'll get to
you in a minute
how did you live
oh
man how did he live
how did he come back to life
hold up
i wasn't feeling how he just randomly
got that random
he shouldn't have just got that random
perkiness man like he was dead
oh so now i'm 21. so every time i die i
go a year older
okay
you know i don't know what you
any regrets now
why are you so
extra
get up
get up
yeah you go get dealt with
i wasn't feeling that i wasn't feeling
that
the warehouse
we going to a warehouse guys
i don't know what this does
there we go
do you climb stuff
oh
okay
what's up homie
not so tough after all
you thought you had something i ain't
even letting them get up
here
i can make it can definitely make it
we put our mind to it
who is this
this big
toki leaky dude
we're gonna get him right now
come on let's go let's go
did you forget how to fight him
i have
i really need to figure out how he's
doing that
this is more about like dodging
man he about to knock me out or kill me
whatever
i gotta learn how to fight this dude
better
you impress me little guy
okay
yeah that's right
the duke caught me off guard he did he
caught me off guard
gotta get rid of them one off the back
want that glass
damn straight i got a weapon there's
like eight of you
it's really hard to
all right come on man
no i'm definitely playing this on a
playstation 5.
you guys don't know me i might be
playing this on an xbox
we gonna need this pipe
they like jump at me i got no issue
using pipes on people
oh
i pity you
we got to get you up out of here
man
charged back fist
yeah let's get that
yeah it might be on xbox you guys don't
know me like that might be i'm playing
this on xbox
how do i do that yeah okay there we go
um
yeah let's get you let's get you on the
ground pick up this weapon too
moving through the road would be a lot
easier with keys all right so we got
keys now
these will be useful
bet you will use the keys right here yep
because that's how things grow
almost there
need to get through that door all right
let's see what's over there come on
quicker
we have a city to deliver too
boss once everything's shipped out of
here
yeah
i don't know what you was trying there
but
did you have something on you no
wax on wax off
i don't like
[Music]
wow i don't like how
how hard it is to focus on one person
like someone will come in randomly and
it will automatically defocus me from
that person or i'm continuously trying
to hit someone and it defocuses off him
again
really you want some more
geez like
i just i don't like that like i'll be
hitting someone else and then someone
will barely tap me and it focuses the
attack on them
not so tough after all
give me one of these
homeboy just fight me see what how'd
that happen
got to fight this super saiyan dude
come here come here
dude over here with super saiyan glowing
like
yeah
how'd that work out for you
[Music]
do i go in here next
i know how to do the directional dodges
that the issue isn't the dodging the
issue is the
how easy it is to knock away who you're
fighting
yeah i've noticed that
i don't like how like whack they
all right so i gotta go through that
door
let's get rid of it
did you forget how to fight
wow
we're going straight back into it man
haven't you had enough
i got
this dude i gotta get rid of this chick
okay
we can't get hit by him
the controls feel a little clunky too
like i don't feel like i'm like in
control of my character 100
just a little bit not too bad
i don't know what structure is i'm
assuming maybe it's your health
they needed like a lock-on system i i
that's what i would want a lock-on
system
so i can focus on one character that i
want to focus on
oh
we going i think he's the first boss
let me get some water
oh
what are you doing
doing these jump kicks oh my god don't
let him hit you with that jump kick
stuff man
he'd be jacking you up
where is his health
[Music]
where is this man's health
oh he got me did the hybrid kick man he
knocked me the hell out
let's try this man
we don't give up we gonna knock him out
why did i go to 29 that time
[Music]
i feel like i should have turned
come on man let's go
let's go
let's go buddy
oh she just backflip over
these flowers don't look that realistic
let's go buddy
all right so i gotta double jump that
oh he
knocked me ass out twice
we're just gonna ride
[Music]
oh he's got a sword
he's got a sword
that's fair
oh some random force just randomly grew
out of nowhere
though this was more realistic
you just teleport my ass to the to the
wilderness
is that what's going on here
just teleport my ass to the wilderness
these people done so they sold to the
devil or something
i gotta remember how to do some of these
moves
oh knocked me out
they don't really
do they explain why he has this ability
by the way
um
[Music]
yeah probably this is the first the
first play through man
i gotta learn the move sets
i think i gotta just
oh
i have spent eight long years preparing
for this
was that the first dude
him
all right so that was that was the dude
that cut my throat
all right so now let's go to the club
man we all want to go to the club don't
we
this game short i don't know how long
this game is uh
live supremacy
yeah the glory is not really there i
will give you that the gore is not
really there
i don't know if i was supposed to hit
them but they got hit anyway
going straight to the front door
yeah
what do you want
not so tough after all
i like that baseball bat
drop your weapon
yeah attica bully out he can't play with
these people
we all know he want to kill me
acting like i'm just to let them hit me
first
the dance floor i like this music
[Music]
i had to get rid of him
leave it to her to throw stuff at
what was that about
the blood is kind of disappointing if
you really like put
what type of game this is
now don't you dare fall don't let her do
that little spinning jar did you kick on
you
oh she doing that dancing fighting style
oh she knocked me the hell out too
i like that let's do that
hmm
[Music]
come on let's go
[Music]
let's grab this
i don't know what structure is i assume
it's your
i need the health card
man i just beat the hell out of
everybody and i couldn't find an access
card
the [ __ ] is this mess
you guys know by now we ain't waiting
we ain't waiting for you either
oh the super saiyan
oh the super saiyan
super sand
we ain't having that
yeah we get rid of super saiyan dude
you ain't hit me with no glass
appreciate it dragon heart
gotta get rid of you
you
and you
what's up
we don't play
sit down
doesn't seem like your friends are
helping you
i didn't make my point
i got two big dudes
i gotta stop the let these dudes hit me
i gotta get this dude yeah cuz he's
almost dead
it's probably best if i get behind them
trying not to die again to the boss
that's probably not gonna happen but i'm
a try
that's closing tonight
uh yeah yeah yeah
what's the matter oh my god i thought i
was about to come in there and just and
just finish that chick she's like nah we
gonna sweep you
48 i'm 48 years old man
can i take you out real quick
whoa
what's the matter
come here come here
i
want to talk about stuff man
are you nervous
those chicks
gave me a little bit of a problem
come on try to swing
what's up boba fett gaming
oh i shouldn't have jumped down here
that wasn't too smart of me
gotta get rid of this big dude
oh the goku dude oh my god
like seriously
big boy man big boy
wow
all right let's try that
oh about to turn 53
yeah
i wonder what age i die at
i'm getting old man i'm getting old
is this the next dude
you are not supposed to be part of
tonight's group nope
let's end this quickly
how fast this dude is
wow this dude
this dude ain't playing
you should have stayed down
[Music]
i can go directly to the burning
i wonder if you keep this stuff even
when you when you die
what am i doing
making sure you guys don't attack me
later
what's what's through door number one
huh guys i know some of you know
i know some of you know where i'm going
what's the door number one
people in the chat tell me
tell me what's in door number one
take an awfully long time for this to
load
considering this is a ps5 one would
think that this would load a lot faster
than it's loading
oh what does this do
step forward
you're about to be tested
i guess i'm the one tested
give me this
yeah
breathing
oh i got knocked out
got hit pretty hard too
this is right
haven't you had enough
you shall not fear death
the camera angle man
a thief
this battle isn't over yet
you're a fast learner
you disappointed oh i got knocked out
you must enjoy the taste of defeat
come on wake up
i'm definitely not beating this dude but
damn
pick up your weapon
you look like you can fight
show me
[Music]
you disappoint me oh i think i'm dead
i think that's it for me man 71.
you impressed me
pathetic
you can barely keep
what
come on wake up
done
the camera angles are horrible man they
really are
forget about it
if you're not on the list you're not
getting inside private backup
what's up
got you
what are you doing
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man these goku mother oh my god i hate
these dudes
what
got to get you up out of there
i felt someone open the door or
something
what's going on
[Music]
gotcha
i don't know guys like
ugh
[Music]
i feel like the trolls are just so
clunky man like i try to keep hitting
that dude it went straight to him just
because they came close to me
[Music]
ah
see i i went to punch the dude on the
left and for some reason it switched to
the dude on the right i didn't switch
him he just switched by himself
i i dodged that
[Music]
i'm not liking those those those combat
styles man i'm just not like i feel like
i don't want to fight you but i feel
like i'm going to be made to fight you
yet
are those your best
wow
see i could definitely
dodge those better
there's no denying those kind of attacks
but
what's the matter
all right is that all
i guess not
got that health back at least
i'm gonna sit here and drink and let
them knock each other out this time
unless one of them's coming up here
what's he doing
all right so i gotta fight these two at
least okay
oh there's three of them
these big dudes are pretty
come on man
wow i went right into what's up bar
probably gave you guys an hour and a
half of this game
hey look i'm not saying this game's bad
or anything but i just don't like the
control schemes i don't like there's not
a lock button like
just not feeling the lack of the control
skins i feel like sometimes i just lose
track of my character for no reason
you are not supposed to be part of
tonight's crew
pathetic you can barely keep up
ugh
i didn't say it was on par i said it was
good just as good and even if i said it
was on par it was better that's my
opinion
like people getting their feelings over
the star wars thing i love the star wars
franchise but people literally know no
no
more whatsoever behind
behind destiny
and they want me to
just
feel that that something's better than
something
yeah i'm dead
can't be real
wake up
i mean if i get hit one more time i'm
dead so it's not like
let me grab this
wow
look when it comes to like
when it comes to destiny versus star
wars like stars has an amazing
star wars has an amazing
background
and i will say that like there's a lot
of lore when it comes to star wars that
makes a lot of sense
but i guess maybe it's because i've
throughout the past few years i've
really played destiny thoroughly so
that's why my opinion i enjoy destiny's
laura moore and i'm not saying i don't
enjoy star wars lord like
star wars got like a really deep lore
too there's no denying that
yeah let's just restart because i want
to i want to try to do that better
i feel like i could do that better
abilities too
no freaking way
you even mention a faction that we know
nothing about you talk about the cabal
i mean we know stuff about the cabal we
just don't know anything like of
substantial evidence like
it's
the cabal is just a war faction that
believe in nothing but war
and we know a lot more about like the
taken we know pretty good about about
the hive
we know a good amount about the fallen
but the cabal that's what i'm saying
what i meant is
they even have factions they haven't
really opened up on
that's what i meant sorry
it didn't make sense
drop your weapon
insane come on guys
go more and more up
oh yeah you gotta jump
[Music]
you are a lot faster for sure
[Music]
not so tough
open it
open up all right this is that cool part
make me bust this damn door down
you got the draw flat
i'ma need that
i mean it's not like we don't know
nothing about the cabal but
we we don't know as much about the cabal
as the rest of them
why is it logged
i hope that makes sense right
is there like a key here somewhere i
grew
that was weird
maybe you didn't register that the event
was over i don't know
that bag's on his way to you
what's going on
get them all man
i don't like these people that throw
stuff at me
[Music]
gotcha
oh yeah the goku dude
you guys know how i feel about these
clowns
they just they're so ridiculous like i'd
rather you just have a good ability from
the start than get your health back and
then
ascend i don't understand that
oh my god
he can't keep up
she say look at that
god damn it would you just die
wasted those two for nothing
you stay there
at least i knocked her out and got my
health back
all right this is where you make the
first big dude
which these dudes like as bad as they
used to be
it's too late to back out now okay
you were saying too late to back out
you don't really have to fight everyone
come on speed this up
i don't want to be late for the club
[Music]
say i didn't want to stop fighting him
that's the stuff that annoys me i didn't
want to start fighting him and it just
it made that choice for me
why didn't they just put a simple log
system in this damn game
i'm about to i'm about to turn this [ __ ]
off i really am
i just i get so annoyed with the
controls
how about you give me that
i just don't have
i them you
i mean i can still knock you guys out
without that stuff
oh my god
it's just annoying
i'm only here for the workouts
[Music]
[ __ ] he's armed
any regrets now
and the tree is just
confusing
it's not a bad game i just feel like
there's a little couple little
things that they could have changed that
would just made it way better
there's a couple of things man
[Music]
don't have to get like a key or
something
i guess not
almost there i need to get through that
door
[Music]
see i didn't stop hitting him
oh great you got that goku stuff
make no sense why he has it but he got
it
why did he move
[Music]
not so tough after all
i ain't gonna lie to you man this is
this is you had enough i ain't playing
this game
[Music]
wow i grabbed him
[Music]
i don't know i don't think there's
double takedowns
i don't know guys i don't know
there's not a lot of narrative either
like i get he picked up this little
thing and that's what's causing me to
grow age but like i felt like they could
have did a better job like having a
narrative to why he's growing age
someone's in here
all right let's go
[Music]
um
um
what
oh
uh
oh he got me
hey stop be nice to each other in there
man
i think it's 50 bucks
on psn i don't know
i'd hit me going full force
[Music]
yeah guys be
nice to each other man
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
i know they did it because they wanna
i was joking with him well i know you
are man people take stuff too seriously
stone patrol carolina
just cool your jets man it's not that
serious uh
you know he was just telling me i gotta
get better at the game which i do it's
not that serious everyone relax
please relax
i actually like to go back to
hold up do they have
forget it
it's probably my last uh run guys
got stuff i got to do man i got the the
girlfriend here and
i'm streaming
any regrets now
wow
i looked at the chat for one second got
knocked the hell out
round two
it's crazy
all right let's go in here again
not last time
not giving people time to turn on
gotta knock them all out
one thing i'm tired of is games getting
their difficulty from
from
control design
and stuff like that because like the
parody i feel a little a little
like not accurate a little
bit i could have got up from that i
could have avoided that kill that death
okay let's
i'm not playing with this chick let's
just
let's just get her up out of there
that move is deadly
the game's well balanced i will say that
the game is definitely well balanced
i just got to get better at
like pairing and stuff
which i'll probably continue streaming
this game on twitch
like some of that health
oh
oh my god
gotcha
let's go straight in here
let's get this dude right here out out
the gate gone
because i have a feeling he he's gonna
try to attack me
got you
destroy you with my dude
these big dudes don't last long when you
got something to hit them with
that's closing tonight oh yeah these two
chicks
are you nervous
man they're hard
they just dodge everything
all right so let's try that
i'm age four to four
wow
see like she literally was on the other
side she jumped
and it came straight to me like she
probably jumped 10 feet
come
can kill it
get rid of this big dude right now
because we don't have the big dude be
doing things man
i need these help
of course he gets the goku thing
i pity you
thought he had me for a second there
the perry's hip in this video is a bit
too difficult i hope they adjust it a
little it's not that it's difficult i
just feel like it's interesting supposed
to be part of tonight's group
let me through
you don't want any trouble
you already found it
can barely keep up
i gotta learn these moves too
53 you should have stayed down
come on man
oh
is there one of those little crystal
things here
i think this hill was my
is these a different set of skills
no they're not
all right let's do this
all right
let's go
not so tough after all
it's very satisfying though like
i'm gonna keep up with this game
after this stream
i'm going to probably stream it on
twitch so definitely follow the iron
lures podcast twitch and i'm going to
stay to because i like it i just got to
get used to it the timing's different
than a lot of other games
step forward
you're about to be tested
oh i knew i was going in that door what
are you waiting for
let me grab this
[Music]
oh i could have used that hell
[ __ ]
oh i got knocked out
this game's fun though it is fun i just
got to get used to the timing and i got
to get used to
how weird they do the the lock-on system
see look that dude ran
and i wasn't even looking at it
use some scary chips
the winner becomes a king and a loser
the thief
this battle isn't over yet
you're a fast learner
you disappoint me
oh i almost had her she was almost done
i do a little bit better last time i got
like 70 something i'm ready
get that health back
i like the lighting they did
real decent art style man
gotta give off to them that they chose a
unique art style
this is the tutorial of how to fight
this dude we're about to fight
you look like you can fight
show me
come on wake up
you can barely keep
oh i knew she got me
oh you can make it a permanent unlock
that's cool
you should have stayed down
you disappoint me
oh what's this
now you guys got to be careful be nice
in that chat man it doesn't it's not
that serious
end of the road
come on
uh
oh my god
this is it man let's enjoy the tastes
defeat
hug daddy
uh
that's it folks
i'll start i'm gonna pick this up on
twitch because
all right let's go to the little
the chilling stream real quick
all right
so i'm gonna pick this up on twitch
because i do enjoy the game and i think
that uh you know with
a lock-on system would have made the
world of difference to me but there's
not a lock-on system on it so i got to
get over that i feel like sometimes when
people get too close to you you end up
targeting on them for some reason i
don't know why that is maybe it's just
something i'm not really
defending you
these busters are telling you to get
good like you aren't good at games look
it's just about me learning the concepts
of the games like right now uh you know
i'm not doing the greatest uh i beat the
first boss got to the second while i was
close to the second i just got to get
better
you know uh he's not wrong got to get
better but that's besides the pack i'm
going to
really fine-tune i'm going to play it
over on twitch i don't know why i'm
going to play it on twitch starting to
get a little bit of how i want to do
stuff on twitch in a kind of a pattern
and and days and find out exactly what
can work with the iop with the attic
show and with